in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen."
The reading from the Sinoxadion for May 29, on which we commemorate our Holy Father Alexander
Archbishop of Alexandria, born in about 250, Saint Alexander during the Episcopate of Saint
Peter of Alexandria occupied an important position among the clergy of the Egyptian metropolia.
A devout man, animated by Holy Zeal, Meek, Friendly, and Monast, he had great love for his brethren
and was especially concerned for the poor. On the death of Achilles, who only occupied
the Episcopal C for five years, it was Alexander who was elected to succeed him in 313.
Taking on the rebuilding of the Egyptian Church after the persecution, he was concerned for the
formation of his clergy and raised to the priesthood and Episcopate, those who had been sanctified
in Askecies and solitude. He had the great Church of Saint Theonas built in Alexandria and organized
assistance for the tried and tested faithful. He had first to confront the supporters of
Bishop Militius of Likopolis, who had ordained priests for the vacant bishoprics during the
persecution and who to justify his schism had adopted the extremist position of those who refused
to reconcile the Lapsi. During the early years, the priest areas, formerly a partisan of the
militians, who had been restored to ecclesiastical communion through Alexander's mediation,
established cordial relations with him, but in 318 he began to contradict the Archbishop's teaching.
He himself with the aid of dialectical argument, teaching that the word of God had not existed
from all eternity, but was simply preeminent among created beings. One could not, therefore, speak
of the unity of the three holy persons of the Godhead. Alexander, a prized of his scheming,
took no immediate measures against areas, attempting to bring him back to Orthodox doctrine through
conversations and fatherly exhortations. But these efforts proved useless and the heresy rapidly
spread all over Egypt, which found itself divided between the Orthodox, the partisans of Areas,
and the militians, who supported the doctrine of Divine Monarchia. Alexander decided to excommunicate
areas, but the latter having found support in Palestine, Syria, and Asia Minor, it was necessary
to convoke a council of a hundred bishops in Alexandria to confirm the sentence and decide that areas
and his disciples should be exiled. In Palestine, the heretic passed himself off as innocent and
persecuted and succeeded in gaining the support of influential prelates, such as Eusebius of
Nicomedia, who met in council and asked Alexander to revoke his sentence and accept him once again
in his communion. But Saint Alexander stood firm and resisted all their solicitations,
in a letter in which he protested against the interference of Eusebius of Nicomedia and made an
expose of the new heresy, he showed that it overturned the whole doctrine of salvation.
When areas posted of approaching the mysteries of faith through syllogisms and philosophy,
Alexander, leaning on the church's tradition, proclaimed that it is because the word is the
son of God by nature, that we are, through him, made sons of God by adoption, and are able to rejoice
in eternal life. And he declared himself ready to die for this holy truth, making the most of
the rivalries between Constantine and Licinius, areas returned to Egypt, where he gained many
partisans among the people through the composition of songs and poems that made his erroneous beliefs
readily accessible. The heresy had acquired a universal dimension when Constantine came to power.
Under the influence of Eusebius of Nicomedia, the emperor wrote to Alexander and
Arius, reproaching them for creating disorder out of nothing, and sent St. Hoseos of Cordova to Egypt
to make a report for him on the situation. Ozeus realized the gravity of the heresy, and on Alexander's
advice, counseled the emperor that it could only be defeated by an ecumenical council.
The following year, in 325, Constantine convoked the first holy and ecumenical council at Nicia.
St. Alexander went there, despite his great age and infirmity, and played a decisive part in it,
seconded by his protégé Saint Athanasius. Arius and his adherents were decisively condemned,
and the Son of God declared to be consubstantial with the Father.
The council also resolved the militian schism, restricting Melitius to his own diocese,
and recognized the archbishop of Alexandria's jurisdiction over Egypt, Libya, and Bentapolis.
Saint Alexander also played a very large part in the fixing of the date of Easter,
and the council decided that the archbishop of Alexandria should, each year, address an
encyclical letter to all the churches announcing the common date of Easter.
This usage persisted until the council of Calcedon in 451, a period during which the greater part of Egypt
fell into monophysicism. The council having ended, St. Alexander returned in triumph to his
episcopal city, where he worked to heal the wounds caused by the heresy and schism,
being inflexible towards attempts made by highly placed men to reestablish areas.
He fell asleep in peace on the 26th of February in 326 or 327, and St. Athanasius was
immediately elected by the episcopal assembly of Egypt to continue with brilliance St. Alexander's
work on defending the true faith and confirming the Church. Through the prayers of our Holy
Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.